HéHélènene, Stéphanie, Luc, bon.
EnEn avant des images en directn
n'n'en a beaucoup parlé la semae
dedernièrere avant que ça survie
héhélas le déranger des analyses
ququand c'est pas arrivé on état
rerendu au 6 janvier américain t
àà l l'assaut parlement, on se
prpréparait au pire, mais le pie
n'n'est pas arrivé.
QuQuoiqu'il y a eu des scènenes
didisgracieuses.
IlIl y a eu des drapeaux nazis,
mamais de façon générale c'était
plplutôt t des gens qui avaient
enenvie de se retrouver et dire
ququ'il y avait trop de mesure.
- - je suis pas allé me promener
sasamedi mais je suis allé me
prpromener au jour lui, est ce e
jeje constatais c'étais sur tout
cece question de la ségrégation
seselon le statut matinal, vous
l'l'avez bien dit, il y a une
coconstellation de récriminatios
faface à l la pandémique se rege
llà-b-bas, mais beaucoup autoure
cecette ségrégation c'est vraimt
ququelque chose qui revient
bebeaucoup, l'environnement est
bobon enfant et les gens sont un
pepeu à l la fêtete et j'aimeras
ququand mêmeme apporter une
prprécision parce que certains
popoliticiens disaient que c'est
papas vrai qu'ils allaient se
lalaisser intimider et que c'étt
popour cela qu'il se présentaitu
PaParlement mais l'idée c'est qe
leles manifestants sont mêmeme s
prproches des portes, il n'y a s
d'd'alumine cimente de
mamanifestants.
- - Stéphanie, commentaire
gégénéral, parce qu'on est passé
d'd'un extrêmeme à l l'autre, ot
papassé de l'analyse au scénario
pepeut-êtrtre trop bon enfant de
sasamedi où c'était les câlilint
totout le monde était beau, peu-
êêtrtre que la vérité est entres
dedeux?
- - Oui ça été une manifestation
mamajoritairement pacifique avec
dedes éléments qui ont voulu ête
dédérangeants comme les gens qui
hahabitent au centre-ville
d'd'Ottawa commencent en avoir
asassez du bruit qui est constat
jojour et nuit, il n'y a pas eue
cacasse mais il y a un certain
cocompte fortement déplorable et
jeje n'ai pas eu besoin de les
rérépéter. on est pas dans un
scscénario de 610 Mons avaient
dédéjà q qu'avant que les gens
ararrivent et y allaient avoir s
éléléments plus dérangeants pari
leles organisateurs et ça s'est
avavéré êtrtre des drapeaux
coconfédérés qui est loin du
memessage principal qui était de
cecelle-ci et le mesure sanitai.
- - le drapeau est devenu le
sysymbole, et qui peut êtrtre un
sysymbole raciste fort.
EnEnvoi Terry Fox qui a été
babarbelé, il y a eu la tombe du
sosoldat inconnu où ils ont uri.
IlIl y a eu, compte tenu du gen,
pepeu de gestes disgracieux, voe
cocompte rendu Luc?
- - S'il y avait u un parallèleà
fafaire avec le 6 janvier c'état
lele fait que c'est une coalitin
ququi n'est pas juste la pour la
vavaccination, des gens qui ont
dadans le passé revendiqué plein
dede choses, moi j'ai toujours
pepensé qu'il ne pouvait pas y
avavoir autant de violence que s
6 6 janvier parce qu'il n'y a ps
dede violence imminent ce qui
prprécèdede l'événement.
DaDans les manifestations Black
LiLives Matter il y a eu des
AmAméricains qui sont sortis de
leleur maison avec des armes doc
lala violence ne s'invente pas
cocomme cela à p partir de la m,
ilil faut qu'il y ait un climate
viviolence et il n'est pas le me
auau Canada qu'aux États-Unis.
- - On va écouter Monsieur Trudu
etet Monsieur Duhaime qui ont
ananalysé tout cela.
- - Je comprends qu'il y a
cecertaines personnes qui
chchoisissent de rejeter
lala science, qui choisissent
dede rejeter l'entraide,
mamais c'est leur choix.
LeLes défis auxquels on est
enen train de faire face dans
nonos chaînenes d'approvisionnet
nene sont pas dûs s aux politiqs
dede vaccination, mais sont dûss
àà l la COVID-19.
CeCe n'est pas en rouspétant
ququ'on va finir cette pandémie,
c'c'est en se faisant vacciné.
GEGÉRARD DELTELL, leader
paparlementaire du PCC
- - Ces gens-là o ont joué,
ililsjouent et vont continuer
àà j jouer un rôlele important.
EtEt ce n'est pas en les méprist
etet en faisant l'amalgame entre
leles imbéciles qui ont commis
leles gestes irrévérencieux
dodont j'ai parlé tantôtt
etet les travailleurs canadiens
hohonnêtetes qui veulent avancer
lala situation qu'on va améliorr
lala situation, bien au contrai.
LeLe premier ministre provoque
leles gens. Et ça, pour nous,
c'c'est très s dommageable
tatant pour la situation actuel,
mamais surtout pour l'unité
ququ'on doit avoir.
EÉRIC DUHAIME, chef,
PaParti conservateur du Québec
- - Il y a plusieurs de leurs
rerevendications que j'appuie,
jeje l'ai dit publiquement et
jeje le répètete, ici, aujourd'.
EtEt si les camionneurs sont
rerendus dans la rue aujourd'hu,
à f faire un convoi, c'est parce
ququ'on a des remparts dans
nonotre démocratie, là, , qui
dedevaient défendre, justement,
nonotre systèmeme démocratique,i
dedevaient défendre nos droits
ciciviques qui ont lamentablemet
écéchoué. Je pense, notamment,
àà d des fédérations, des
reregroupements de gens
d'd'affaires, le Barreau,
leles tribunaux, les défenseurs
dedes droits civiques.
IlIl y a très peu de gens qui
sese sont levés par rapport
àà l la dérive que le Québec
a a subie depuis deux ans.
- - Alors autre tour de table,
paparce que c'est une chose de
didire qu'il y a trop de mesures
sasanitaires, mais c'est une aue
chchose que de dire que le virus
n'n'existe pas et qu'ils ne
veveulent pas se mettre du poisn
dadans le bras, c'est ça qui met
cecette soue plaque complexe à
ananalyser?
- - Si difficile de les défendre
tatandis que les vaccins
dédécontaminés que ça fait de ns
dedes rats de laboratoire, maisl
fafaut reconnaîtrtre que Monsier
LeLegault joue un jeu politiquet
lele fait depuis le début c'est-
didire qu'il a constaté que d'êe
dudu côtété des pros mesurent
sasanitaires c'est plus populaie
paparce qu'il y a une forte
mamajorité des Canadiens qui sot
dede ce côtété-là e et de renvor
totous les autres sont des
momoindres amants des accords ds
lele plan des six obscurantismes
ceces gagnants politiquement et
popolarise l'échiquier politique
c'c'est dangereux et certains
avavaient fait un lien avec ce
coconvoi et le trumpisme et moie
vovois le lien ailleurs, les
mémédias se sont moqués de 30 et
cocomment Madame Clinton avait
paparlé de ces fanatiques comme
dédéplorable et ils se sont
trtrouvés hébéter que de voir il
ététait devenu président et il t
llà l le problèmeme c'est qu'on
ararrêtete d'écouter l'autre qud
onon n'oublie notre capacité
d'd'altérité et on ne comprend
plplus et ce convoi c'est peut-
êêtrtre une occasion de s'écoutr
dadavantage mais ce n'est pas ce
ququ'on constate de la part de
MoMonsieur Trudeau.
- - Monsieur Trudeau, Monsieur
LeLegault a tendu la main hier,n
n'n'en parlera, mais là u un peu
tetendu la main en sentant qu'il
nene fallait pas, parce qu'il y
avavait beaucoup de monde et ce
n'n'était pas tous les éliminer
d'd'extrêmeme droite, est-ce que
MoMonsieur Trudeau devrait faire
unun ou c'est payant politiquemt
dede ne pas faire ce pas?
- - Comme Hélènene l'a dit, on e
vovoyait déjà d dans les électis
ququand Monsieur Trudeau part de
lala pandémie ou des mesures
sasanitaires et s'adresse toujos
àà l la mèrere sur les sens adrs
àà l la minorité mêmeme si parma
mimineure et ce n'est pas tous s
cocomplotiste il y a des questis
sosont très s valide à p poser s
drdroits humains, sur le droit à
SuSubject ses de façon conscien,
çaça a bien avec certaines
rerestrictions mais ça ne veut s
didire que ce sont des complotie
ouou des gens d'extrêmeme droit,
mamais Monsieur Trudeau ne fait
papas cette nuance est
efeffectivement sacré de la
didivision, et ça pose donc
prproblèmeme pour des parlements
ququi souhaiteraient tendre la
mamain parmi leur électorat pari
leles gens qui se posent encore
dedes questions sur les mesures
sasanitaires ou qui en ont ras--
bobol ou qui sont dans une
sisituation difficile
acactuellement, mais on n'a pas
l'l'impression de discuter.
- - C'est la différence entre
écécouter quelqu'un et dire qu's
nene sont pas d'accord, ou le
reregarder de haut en disant
ququ'ils ne comprennent rien?
- - Oui sauf que la situation de
MoMonsieur Trudeau est trèss
cocompliquée parce qu'il fait fe
auaux parties conservateurs et i
ilil s'est pas gênéné pour polir
lele dossier avec des appuis de
plplusieurs députés à d des
dédéclarations très s très s las
susur le refus de la vaccination
etet des mesures sanitaires.
..
IlIl y a un temps où il faut
memettre son poing sur la tablet
didire qu'on a de l'empathie ete
lala compassion, mais il faut se
fafaire vacciner et il faut
rerespecter les mesures et on ne
pepeut pas juste dire je vous
cocomprends, il faut dire je vos
cocomprends mais nous sommes à
l'l'époque où il va falloir que
totout le monde fasse un certain
rerespect des mesures les mesurs
sosont parfois contredites trois
esest parfois mal expliqué, et e
gogouvernement n'est pas blanc
cocomme neige, les commentateurs
nene sont pas blancs comme neig,
mamais il l faut les respecter l
esest à l la têtete de ce mouvea
tetentant de faire respecter les
memesures.
MoMoi je lui donne ma
cocompréhension.
- - L'autre question que ça pos,
onon parlait du débordement un u
mamais dans l'ensemble non, mais
HéHélènene, combien de temps?
LaLa ville d'Ottawa ne peut pas
êêtrtre paralysée pendant une
sesemaine?
- - Non il y a beaucoup
d'd'agacement de la parure des
hahabitants la manifestation est
trtrès s dérangeante, ont mentié
cocombien de sens sont-ils?
IlIl va y avoir des pannes sèchs
ququi vont amener les gens
ququitter, mais la question se
popose et je vais oser en
paparallèlele, rappelons-nous ia
dedeux ans à p pareille date, le
papays était paralysé par les
blblocages de chemin de fer et r
dedes auteurs un et/ou leurs
alalliés partout à t travers les
etet ça aussi ça avait perturbé
leles chaînenes d'approvisionnet
etet empêchcher les gens d'aller
trtravailler dans certaines vils
paparce que leur train de banlie
nene tournait plus et Monsieur
TrTrudeau, n'avait pas voulu
dedemander aux gens de plier
babagages avant deux semaines.
IlIl faut quand mêmeme voir les
paparallèleles dissidents la
sisituation qui nous intéresse
leleur a demandé des aujourd'hui
DiDi s'en aller alors que la
dedernièrere fois il a été capae
d'd'attendre 14 jours.
- - Vous déconnez plus patient
avavec les Wet'suwet'en qui
blbloquez les voies ferrées?
- - Ouais.
- - Séparation de déloger des 18
roroues?
- - Oui et pour revenir sur la
crcrise Wet'suwet'en en ai pas é
plplus patient il y a eu des
alaltercations avec les forces
popolicièreres assez rapidementt
d'd'ailleurs on a été plusieurs
pepersonnes aurait marqué le :
dedeux mesures de plusieurs
mamanifestations qui ont déjà eu
lilieu dans le Centre Bell
d'd'Ottawa et comment le chef de
popolice réagit.
CÇa reste et ça laisse les
rérésistants d'Ottawa avec
bebeaucoup de questions je pens.
- - Vous dîtetes qu'on est plus
papatient avec des membres de la
mamajorité?
- - Certainement on a mêmeme vus
phphotos circuler ou le corps de
popolice d'Ottawa et le corps de
sésécurité semblait sympathiser
avavec les manifestations et
prprendre des photos alors qu'oa
dédéjà v vu les mêmemes corps de
popolice êtrtre beaucoup moins
papatient vis-à-v-vis d'autres
mamanifestants qui étaient plus
papacifiques?
- - Comme?
- - Idle No More, la classemenet
dede, ou les réponses des corpse
popolice était beaucoup plus
mumusclé.
- - Quelquefois la police, il ya
papas mal de monde et il y a tot
unun quadrilatèrere qui est
paparalysé?
- - Je suis d'accord avec mes dx
cocollègugues, on a entendu quee
momouvement de la plupart de ses
mamanifestants et qu'il reste un
grgroupe assez marginal des
pepersonnes et en évoque les
ququestions de sécurité, souvent
ilils sont réels, pas toujours,
mamais souvent, pour dire qu'ily
a a danger qu'il reste là e enc,
cocomme si on décide que les
enenfants doivent passer par lùu
leles abus lancent, c'est commea
ququ'ils réagissent effectivemet
dede dire que le centre-ville et
ococcupé et que c'est inacceptae
ilil y a eu plein de
mamanifestations inacceptables
dadans le passé et on ne peut ps
gégérer la manifestation sur la
babase de nos opinions.
- - C'est quand mêmeme complexe
paparce qu'ils prennent beaucoup
dede place, Marie Victorin hier,
MoMonsieur Legault a présenté
ShShirley Demers mon, une ex-
prprésidente de la physique, eta
étété intéressant parce qu'ellea
étété très s critique envers le
gogouvernement Legault.
OnOn va entendre Monsieur Legaut
etet Charlie, et elle a fait le
papari qu'à l l'intérieur on pot
chchanger les choses si elle est
élélue.
OnOn écoute.
- - Il y a des gens qui vont ête
susurpris parce que jusqu'à t tt
rérécemment, depuis quatre ans,
dede la FIQ. Donc c'est possibl,
ququ'effectivement, vous trouviz
dedes traces d'endroits où
onon était pas t toujours d'acc.
DoDonc, c'est très s bienvenu
d'd'avoir quelqu'un comme Shirly
popour venir aider notre équipe.
SHSHIRLEY DORISMOND, candidate,
CACAQ, Marie-Victorin
- - J'ai dit des choses,
jeje les assume totalement,
mamais l'ouverture est là,,
pupuis il y a pas de consensus
susur la définition, puis
c'c'est normal, on est dans
unune société avec différentes
opopinions, mais l'important
c'c'est de lutter contre
lele racisme, et le gouvernemen,
ilil est prêt t à l le faire.
- - Tour de table.
- - c'est un grand coup pour
MoMonsieur Legault parce qu'il t
vovoter pour nous et voter pour
elelle et ça va êtrtre un vote r
lele changement alors que
vrvraisemblablement voter pour e
gogouvernement ce n'est pas un
vovote pour le changement?
- - C'est une grosse pointure et
onon sent qu'on veut déloger les
paparties québécois qui étant
cecelle de Marie Victorin depuis
dedes décennies et ça sera
inintéressant de voir si elle et
élélue qu'elle poste et héritera
etet jusqu'à q quel point elle
popourra changer les choses.
- - Je dis bravo à c cette damei
nonous rappelle que les partis
popolitiques n'est pas
momonolithique et on a le droit
d'd'avoir des diversités d'opinn
àà l l'intérieur et c'est comme
cecela que les parties évoluent
ququand il y a des éléments
didissidents donc bravo et elle
s's'en est pas cachée.
- -